so what happened on Dancing with the
Stars who the [ __ ] did you fall in love
with I didn't fall in love but I did
fall in like show love I mean like
whatever you know what it was and it was
them you know it was the guy that won
the the Bobby bones I fell in love with
Bobby I mean Bobby bones is a DJ right
yeah yeah he's a country DJ he's worse
than country radio you guys hooked up
yeah holy [ __ ] yeah during the show and
we had to keep it super secret he's like
a Ryan Seacrest type right yes happening
I know very successful very just like
bones cute that he's a bad dancer
justice well he was just as bad as I was
but he won because he's a big following
I know I didn't know I could have one
being a terrible dancer so why are you
not mrs. Bobby bones well how did that
romance before um so I got voted off the
show we were like hooking up like
lightly like I was making out yeah I
mean I I think we spent several nights
together and I didn't even like take off
my clothes like we were just really I
was really making him work for it right
I wasn't sure of him good good for you
yeah that's my new thing
oh you guys made out some light petting
yes very light because I was like I just
don't know and I was still seeing my
ex-boyfriend at the time like I was that
was so up in there and I was like I
don't know what I want to do with this
and then um he's expressed his feelings
like he was falling for me and I was
like well let me just close up the
ex-boyfriend thing then and maybe I can
be open to exploring this because I
don't feel right about that if and then
as soon as I close up the ex-boyfriend
thing guess who doesn't want to hang out
with me anymore
oh no it's kind of like that what you
mean he ghosted you
he kind of ghosted me could you picture
I mean after you got kicked off the show
I got kicked off the show he continued
on and I didn't expect to stay in touch
I mean that show was wild you don't he's
in LA I'm a New Year's even have time to
hook up with them um where do you do it
I mean in between in between spray tans
it was
please not get it like trailers and
stuff but it was really emotional more
than anything we were both just like
talking about how hard this all was and
how emotional it all was and how and he
moved in and kiss yeah uh-huh
um you kissed him no I he definitely I
don't make the first move anymore so he
he made it the first move but it was it
was a lot of like come on dude like when
are you and that happens with me a lot
with guys they don't kiss you I don't
they
I just don't I'm not good at flirting or
something and I always made the first
move and I've recently in the past
couple years been like no more first
moves I'm always the one to be like are
we gonna make out what's going on right
but that doesn't work for me so now I'm
like I have to because I like talking
for guys you're on a show together you
know yeah he's probably thinking maybe
she's not really into me maybe she's
just kind of being emotionally there for
me that's why he was like I'm more I
think he mentioned me to at one point I
go I'm in your bed topless no yeah